all right so we looked at last last
session and we got to the point of
talking about but not really exploring
this thing called the categorical
imperative and you'll remember that one
of the things that contet said that I
called your attention to us he wanted to
find the principle the unifying idea of
morality and saw that with duty and the
goodwill Duty is one side of the command
did what was the other side of the claim
so you remember I also said that one of
the things that was going to tribute
with count was terminology figuring out
what all these words if you went to the
dictionary but you looked up some of
these terms they may not actually have
got the same definition as contents use
them so it may not have been helpful so
part of what I'm going to do is just
tell you what all these different terms
before we actually talk about the
categorical imperative to want to work
our way towards so a little bit of
review you know what is the key for kind
of acting or willing and accordance with
do that one thing that gets you on the
way to more with us so think about all
the different duties that you have
you're a student you're a son or a
daughter you may be a brother or sister
certainly we have friends that you feel
you have certain duties towards your
citizen you're a human being in relation
to other human beings right yeah you
have a whole bunch of different duties
obligations however it is that you want
to think about them some of them you
don't think about very often some of
them weigh on your mind all the time I
think when you do these things do you do
them for the sake of fulfilling your
duty or are you doing it for some other
reason for cop that's what's deciding
that's the motive that I tells you
whether it's a moral action or whether
it's it's a good action in some sense
but not morally good so if I will use
myself as an example so I should come to
class prepared right you guys think that
in general I shouldn't just get up here
and walk in and sort of make stuff up as
I go along
or sort of rest on my laurels you know
don't review the cuz I taught that last
semester in a little be there in my mind
what do you think are you getting at
money's worth if I show up up here we're
supposed to go for that you pay what
they do to be conservative just wouldn't
you yeah you're right I have a duty to
prepare for class and part because I
have a duty to educate you and so in
order for mine in order for me to
fulfill my main duty which is to
well I have to be prepared so it's a
sort of duty then it's presupposed by
another duty what could my reasons be I
can't stand this stuff you know I'm not
a guy by the way you know so maybe I
didn't
I only prepare camp because I'm getting
paid to do it and it's part of the
Canada a good job I need to teach you
cops but you know I can't wait to get
through it so we can get to the airlock
would that be moral action on that would
be good action it's better for me to
teach you well than to teach you a
sloppy way all right you've all had the
professorship weren't prepared I know
what I've been doing it for the right
reason what could be some other reasons
that might not be the best reasons for
doing my doing my job well yeah
yeah no I don't qualify for that cuz I'm
a part-timer here but what's it no no I
wish I was
there's a nice place to teach you're
right yeah if you were a college
professor and you're not tenured yet you
you need to do you work well in research
and scholarship service and then
teaching you need to do that well so
that you can get tenure so you can have
this sort of permanent secure position
and then you notice that some people
when they get tender
you can tell that that's their motive
because then suddenly once they get
tenure it all goes out the door right
that's one way you can tell if something
what somebody's motivated by that they
keep on doing that after that motivation
is one that's a good one what else any
other reasons I could be motivated to do
a good thing but not for the you know
the best one one of my sort of ego or
soft worth or something like that
depends on as they call it the sage on
the stage person who gets to teach there
are some professors for whom I think
just is actually a motive where they
they get a kick out of being the person
who gets to talk a lot of times they're
not the ones of encouraging keep talking
another way to test it - isn't it work
maybe I don't want you to like me you
know maybe I have a intense desire to be
liked and
come to the conclusion that one way I
can make that desire take you know take
shape is for teaching your Conte
and giving you the tools that you need
to understand this complicated text let
me kind of strange think of it that way
right a lot that's plausible again would
that be a good would that be a morally
good mode I think that's a decent motive
wanting to be liked
that's better than say wanting to
inflict the pain of studying content
here but it's not morally right if my
mccoshen I should be doing this because
of the intrinsic value of the act itself
because it's the right thing to do and
all these other things could actually
interfere with them the conscience
really attuned to the fact that
sometimes camping what we think of as
good motives could lead us to get a
little bit sloppy - to make the right
decision up to a certain point and then
not make the right decision like that
like the professor who just doesn't to
get tenure if you realized now I'm not
doing this just to get tenure but let's
let's do a hypothetical situation let's
say it wasn't me and you're in my class
and you know you really start getting
into the materials things start to click
for you you start to make associations
you say yeah this this stuff is worth
studying and you come to class and
you're excited about it
we have great discussions in class and
you know you come in prepared and then
we do some stuff on the board and then
talking back and forth you leave the
class and you feel like you're really
gaining something and you you thought if
there was like a connection there that I
cared about you as a student not just
you know as a mass of students but about
each one of you the student and then you
found out that you were the class right
before I got and
as soon as I got tenure I started
treating students a bit differently
start showing off not as well prepared
wasn't interested in students questions
didn't encourage them to talk that sort
of thing with that would that make you
rethink your experience would you look
back at and say you know maybe it wasn't
the way I thought it was with we're
going through that sort of process of
mentally revising your your impressions
what do you that's a good way to put
what do you think would you feel like -
now I didn't come up with mining am I
saying I want impress this upon you that
I care about your development as
students and moral beings or anything
like that but you would feel like in a
broader sense right and you would have
felt kind of deceived huge right think
about that as we go through this that
feeling of being used because when we
get to the second formulation of the
categorical imperative that's going to
be a lot about music and not music so
what are our motives that's something
that we can ask another thing that kind
of wants us to ask are we sure that
we're doing things for the right motives
because it's awfully easy I think all of
you have had this experience doing the
right thing and doing it for what you
feel are the right motives at the time
and then later on you realize that your
motives were not quite so pure as you
leave them to be and then you have gone
through those sort of epiphanies yet
I'll give you an example on my part
again because I live twice so that means
I probably screwed up twice as much as
you guys
there was a time
when I was this when it came to the
morality of that wasn't bad guy
waterways but we came to
boyfriend-girlfriend stuff I would not
only not cheap but not give the
impression even that I would avoid any
sort of occasion or impression of was
possibly cheating and why did I do that
well I came to realize after a while
that it wasn't cuz I was a particularly
good guy it's a good thing to be the
kind of person to be not only wooden
sheep but also would wait even getting
in the impression that something might
be going on would you agree to but I was
doing it for the wrong reason I was
doing it so I could think of myself as a
good person not to actually be a good
person you know and I think that the
action of not cheating that's not that
you shouldn't she but you know that
wasn't the real kicker there it was the
you know acting as if I couldn't
possibly be tempted that way
I was completely reliable now if you
have a boyfriend a girlfriend and you
were worried about that sort of thing
and they at least acted like they were
completely reliable that would make you
feel pretty good wouldn't it yeah and I
you know I don't make a practice of
cheating to just stress this body okay I
did she go I'm one girlfriend way way
back
more than fifteen years ago and I
remember you know all the things that
led up to and the consequences and all
those sorts of things I remember at a
certain point this persona that I built
off of things
would never even consider that sort of
candidates all because it wasn't
something that I could truly rely on
anyway and you know happened during
graduate school all people changing and
we can come up with all sorts of
rationalizations for but I think about
doing the wrong thing that I had a
pretty great something really deeply
about the process and that happened in
part because I was doing things for the
wrong motives and I'd actually convinced
myself for a long time yes I'm doing
things for the right motives we have a
tendency towards self-deception conv
wants to warn us away from them so
that's why he's stressing so much you
know we have to think about this we have
to use reason we think about reason as
being something like a cleaner you know
a caustic cleaner that you use to wipe
away all of the grime and accretions of
things and you know so you've got
whatever it is if you're studying
shining up all of its features clearly
defined and you can now take a closer
look at it it's going to hurt it's going
to dissolve things away but it also know
that it's going to leave the genuine
features of whatever it is that you're
studying so the categorical imperative
is supposed to work like that so let's
think about this term in period what
does it embarrass you guys we've all
studied foreign languages I think right
so some of you studied Spanish and
French or German or Italian yeah Tech
has this - what is when you say an
imperative
that's usually a seen as a mood in these
languages yeah a command very good if I
say would you please close the door
that's a request if I say close the door
left that's a command and in English we
don't actually distinguish it but in
these other languages you'll have a
different
you know because there was inflection
now think about commands and think about
rules I brought this up I think last
class if I take this pen and I let it go
what's going to happen guaranteed it's
been fall which we need you to make the
experiment there go should we do it
again you know we can do it as many
times as we like so it's gonna fall why
is that grammar and then we talk we can
talk about a wall or gravitation right
and you probably don't think about this
in these terms every time that you're
watching an object fall but everything
is everything in the physical world is
governed by rules by the autism can I be
in the same place as this podium at the
same time I can try
I remember a chemistry professor who
would give us extra credit if we do it
walk into walls full speed to
demonstrate the fact that two physical
bodies cannot be in the same space at
the same time even if they're mostly
controllers of space what about you
you're a physical being right there's
all sorts of the laws of affect
consequences if you take arsenic what's
going to happen to you you're gonna die
all right if you don't need you're gonna
die there's all sorts of things that
could destroy your body
what about is a moral being
what about is a being that that wills
that chooses are you subject to some
sort of necessity the way that the drop
if I were to drop the iPhone gravity
would make it go down the iPhone they
have to do that some people think you
are some people they call this
determinism they say well they just your
brain is just wired this way you have to
choose this you know some people are
mean people do they choose to be mean
people no just turned out that way maybe
they were abused as kids they didn't get
the love that they need it or somebody
did terrible things to them or there's
chemical problems with their brain or
you know their constant drinking and
drug use has burned out certain centers
of their brain that allow them to
empathize we could go on and on and on
right concepts well no that's not true
you're different than other things you
can actually make choices because this
is where we did say you know what makes
you human reason the rationality there
but what being a reasonable being allows
you to do is to not only you know see a
wide range of different alternatives and
seek want of fact and that's one thing
but to decide for yourself you get to
decide not only what you do but who you
are not not you know fully I mean those
of you that are men unless you have some
sort of you know operation with a bunch
of hormones and things like that you're
stuck being men those are you are women
and all the same thing but you get to
choose what kind of person you're going
to be so you can choose what your
motives are you can choose whether to
think about this or not
when you choose like that every time do
you do it you're giving yourself an
imperative again you probably haven't
thought about it this way have you you
ever think of yourself is giving
yourself commands maybe once in a while
like you're out running and you know you
run five miles but you're trying to go
six and now you there's the big bill and
you start talking to yourself and say
all right I know you're really tired
just make it through this and you'll be
done you might talk to yourself like
that all right you know it's two o'clock
in the morning and you're still working
on a paper or project and your your eyes
are bleary and you're saying you know
just go to sleep you have a strong
desire a motivation to and the work you
know wrap it up and get it done you say
come on stick with it you know this is
worth something to you you know this is
X amount of points in your grade and you
want to do a good job what are you doing
there if you if you actually tell
yourself to do something whether you
tell yourself to go to sleep or you tell
yourself to keep working on you're
giving yourself an imperative you may
not think of it as doing that because
you're used to inheritors being all the
things that other people tell you to do
right which language did you take
Spanish okay so in Spanish class you
know your teacher actually gave you a
lot of appearance right listen to me
right now or take on your ear your pad
or write this down or take the test
those are telling you what to do you're
not used to thinking of imperatives as
something you impose on yourself Lacan
says we do now there's different kinds
of imperatives with different kinds of
rules or laws that you give yourself he
called some of these and areas of skill
and I think you're gonna write to this
very easily if you want to accomplish a
certain task there's certain things you
have to do it right so if you want to
pass this class what do you have to do
what are just some basic things
what's up do assignments yeah
participate then Sherlock right okay so
let's just take those so do the
assignments participate in show up you
have some sort of end that's passing
this class
great attitude by the way glad that you
have it if you want to attain that end
you have to do those things you've given
yourself that imperative you've actually
chosen every single one of you to do
these things right you're all here
you all chose to show up you nobody made
you show up except for you imposing this
on yourself I didn't make you show up
I'm glad you did but I didn't make you
do that you made yourself to that that's
part of what it means to be an adult
right so you get the credit for that I
don't get the credit for that you do and
so if you want to attain that dead end
that's what you do if you want to like
take myself I don't want to lose the
weight that I got to lose what should I
do
brain surgeon to figure this one out
right yeah
you don't think probably the last do you
know how much I like to heat how rich I
like to make the fruits of the keep what
else I should probably exercise our
exercise more right
my level of exercise is certainly not
that high if I don't have that and if I
want to attain that goal that's a good
for me then I should do these things
that's what we call a you know if you
want to do this then you should do this
now could the ends be bad things too
if you want to tell somebody what's a
good
now actually we have a different name if
you want to kill somebody you don't want
to get caught right then you should make
it look like an answer is that a good
thing to do it's good in the sense that
it keeps you on prison but then again
maybe belong in prison if you're killing
people I think you're killing so the end
could be a good or bad thing if it's a
matter of skill or what cause then we're
also coordinated by another thing so you
know this is all over the men we have
all their hands and waters yeah if you
want to keep your shoes on you should
probably tie them that's you know a very
trivial example of this we also help
with the motivation of happiness all of
us do want to be happy and that means
the satisfaction of our desires of
inclination spur hunt you all have
desires right y'all motivated by them
you're conscious of that least most of
your desires I think what do you have to
do to attain it well there's certain
things that you want to do if you want
to say stay out of trouble
what should you do
obey the law that that's probably a
start right and you can say yourself I
will obey the law because I want to be
happy or if I want to be happy that I
have to obey the law to stay out of
trouble that's actually they can totally
happy I think right what else do you
guys want we've talked about this a
number of times
and wealth will be part of that one what
do you have to do in order to be wealthy
to be comfortable let's say I'm not sure
all of you know and these are screws
rolling in the gold coins kind of rich
yet you need have a job that's that's a
big one right there yeah and you know
that's a same job you probably need a
job that pays fairly well and those kind
of jobs tend to be skilled work right
I've worked a lot of unskilled what else
can you spend anything you like should
you like rack up the credit card debts
that's probably a good way not to have
high interest there's all sorts of
techniques that you can use to this
following most techniques to make you a
good person it there's a good to it
right it's better to be financially
independent than to be dependent let
alone you know deeply in debt but it's
not morally good is it what do you think
at least from a Content perspective our
society
their confidence say no you know that's
hypothetical okay we're all motivated by
happiness but the goal is not actually
to be happy the goal is to be good
people doing the things that are going
to make us happy
those are conditionals are merely
hypothetical we get to the categorical
imperative when we start doing things
and the answer to why are you doing that
is it's the right thing to do it's what
I want to do and so they says well why
do you want to do it and you say it's
told you it's the right thing to do now
you're actually doing things according
to the categorical imperative notice
these things aren't good some of the
time but not all this is always
if you want people to like you all of
you want people to like it right do you
know you know okay
let's we'll come back to that so if you
want people to like you what do you have
to do what are some good ideas that's
probably at the top of the list be nice
to people don't come out of your way to
take them off right now notice not
everybody has that desire not everybody
has that goal in life and there may be
situations in which you don't want
people like you to write if you're going
into a boardroom and carrying out a
negotiation you know over some some
financial things do you necessarily want
everybody in the border yet have warm
fuzzy feelings towards you probably not
fear maybe even hate you but you know
bargaining right maybe you want them to
think you're a little bit not so appease
you offer a higher thing now notice your
goals can change from situation to
situation when it comes to certain
imperatives imperatives of skill
don't hold for everybody they hold for
if you want to accomplish this end then
you need to do this but if you don't
want to accomplish this end you don't if
you don't want to guess this class not
everybody wants to pass this class
everybody in this class session does but
I've got somebody in my last class
session we've never shown up the entire
semester
doesn't seem kind of weird from a
financial point of view they paid for
the class personally I know it's
probably parents
yeah isn't that already something
classic that's true that's oh yeah yeah
at this point they didn't this you have
to semester just about things so yeah my
email them and never got response maybe
give me something happened and another
student who once there for like the
first for class sessions amended just
quit coming yeah you know this much mess
pretty much themselves but they maybe
they don't care maybe they're not
interested in in that that goal maybe
they found some other thing that's so
when it comes to the imperatives of
skill they have to do with particular
goals that we have they could be baffles
- I mean if I really don't like my
neighbor and I want to kill them and I
want you to avoid getting in trouble for
killing them might I think about the
best way to get to that end
that's what detective novels are made of
aren't they they sort of retrace you
know the perfect crime occurring now
let's see if we can unravel it or think
about CSI or long order and these cop
shows they spend a lot of time trying to
untangle the process getting to that end
getting away with the crime it means
that the person used to discover so
imperatives of skill could be good or
bad what's one thing that we all do
desire
what do you think
yeah yeah isn't what you're gonna say
but we don't know I mean that would be
one of those things under the
imperatives of skill you wanna make
money you have to do this but not
everybody does but everybody does desire
to be happy and then oftentimes money
it's a component of happiness
comic-con's happiness our satisfaction
of all our desires and inclinations and
there aren't also certain hypothetical
imperatives that have to do with
happiness if you want to be happy than
one thing you probably need to do early
on is figure out what actually makes me
happy you're an awful lot more likely to
wind up being happy if you have some
conception of what that actually means
for you
right because it can vary from situation
to situation so we could we could
arrange it in terms of if you want to be
happy then you should think about what
makes me happy you should explore what
makes me happy as a real philosophical
question now if you do that does that
make you a morally good person I don't
say no we all do desire happiness but
when we acted in that way we're still
acting according to a hypothetical
imperative if you want this then you
should do this can't work of a parrot if
there's no gift that it holds across the
board and it makes satisfaction of Duty
or doing the right thing
the motive in all these other cases
something else at the moment I want to
kill my neighbor get a waiver that my
motive is getting rid of somebody I
don't like
and staying out of trouble that's not
doing the right thing for its own sake
is it first of all it's not even doing
the right thing but it's not being
wouldn't even if it was doing the right
things it would be doing through the
right saying because this person takes
me on or thinking about losing your
temper right when you've lost your
temper everybody is a different example
when you lose your temper and you
realize that you did the wrong thing
what should you do right you should
sometimes we actually get mad about the
fact that we apologize what's that what
you brought yeah
pride is this is something that
interferes with that so yeah I used to
have a really bad anger problem not even
a little few years ago and like during
baseball it was the worst and what I
don't know I'm just so competitive yeah
and I would just get so upset my dad was
my coat made it worse he would always
keep Tommy like not to get upset in I
have to tell somebody that's angry to
not be angry but other stories yeah
that's that's true yeah calm down yeah
cuz a lot of times too then you think
this person is trying to manipulate you
know yeah
so you get angry you blow up at somebody
you say things maybe you don't mean that
you should apologize right you could
have a lot of different motives for
apologizing maybe you need to get back
on that person's good side was there
your boss
are you are you doing that's your motive
are you doing the right thing which is
to apologize before the right reason
just outside of duty no good you want to
cover your rear right maybe you want to
apologize and you want to get it in
quickly so that you get to still get to
go on the trip with this person again if
that's the main reason you're not doing
you're doing the right thing but you're
not doing it motivated by dude it's not
a unit follow you can't work if you're
following some hypothetical improvements
for happiness or skill so if we want to
figure out what actions would be
motivated by duty if we want to figure
out whether something is the morally
right thing to do it's good the essence
or the touchstone so conch gives us this
categorical imperative and he gives us
three different formulations of it and
we're not going to look at the third
formulation today we'll look at that a
little bit next class today we're just
gonna look at number one and number two
in part because these are a bit easier
to wrap their heads around these are the
ones that most commentators probably
matter of fact sometimes when people
teach and talk so this one has to do
with universalizing actions this one has
to do with treating people as admins as
having a certain human dignity and not
just
I use
and they both end up having the same
conclusions they're two different ways
of looking at the same so if you look at
the first one you've got a couple key
ideas that is if Matt some of your in
action words would become true your will
Universal luggage so in order to make
sense of that you have to know to
maximize right we talked about that last
class maximum is a sort of way of
generalizing what your reaction was
going to be so if I talked about killing
my next-door neighbor and hiding the
body so that I stay out of trouble
my maxim might be something like
whenever I have a person who really
irritates me I will kill them and make
sure that I had body whenever I have a
person who here it takes me and they
want to stay out of trouble I will kill
them and hide the body that could be the
max yeah like her our research favorite
is quite a lot of folks to articles I
thought he always said to maxim of
such-and-such theory is I saw it use
that yeah council not the only person to
use the outside Aristotle talks about
Maxim's in his rhetoric this is the way
continuity public and as sort of the
general rule lot sometimes Maximus is
used also to be like a proper a bird in
the hand is worth two in the bush
we've all heard that one so what does
that mean that means that it's better to
take the opportunity that's actually
there and give that up for two
I can come later there's a nice one too
better to seek forgiveness than ask
permission it'll be a match I don't
think hunt would go along with that but
you know we have all heard that one
before right I think people use that
when they want to do something but they
might get drunk better to ask better to
ask forgiveness afterwards them to ask
permission so it's a man saying any
action that you pick if you know the
motivation behind it you can come up
with what the maximum is if the maximum
works for me it would have worked for
you too so if you were considering
taking care of unwanted neighbor and
staying out of trouble that could be
your Maxim bringing pleasure to others
at no cost to myself you know whenever
I'm in a situation where I can bring
pleasure to others without any cost to
myself I will do so that would be a max
maybe some of you who actually act
according to that whenever I'm in a
situation in which I can bring pleasure
for others and no cost of myself I will
say screw them and not do it that would
be a different maxim right
hopefully I do not operate a creditor
that man so you have a mass I'm a basic
idea general rule actors of the match
them were to be calm three or well as
universal language can you take that
maxim and make it into the universal law
of nature can you say that it should
hold in every circumstance it should
apply to every that's a big question can
you say that everybody should act in
that way when you were a kid think about
some of the things that you wanted to do
we're your parents what if everybody did
and some of them are kind of trivial
like you want to go somewhere all the
other kids are doing this they still say
that your leftover dish and it's kind of
funny because your parents are in my
generation so that means that your
parents are saying the exact same things
that we heard as kids I'm betting that
my parents are the exact same thing or
mayor of kids who knows how long this or
privacy say what's that we'll probably
all say this anyway I'm going to bet
probably you will you'll use this you're
probably not gonna whip out let's say
God would say then you should be able to
universalize your maximum you'll say the
thing about the bridge my my favorite
was in one of my classes where you're
talking about how if Society has become
more ethical or more on ethical yeah and
I made the statement that if you look at
like older people who are in their 80s
or 90s dearly my generation we see
better things are different now and they
state and my parents say this anything
and I'm pretty damn sure we're gonna say
the same thing the interesting thing is
when you serve like reading the
histories of those times you start to
realize they're kind of looking at you
know the rose colored glass piece that
actually they weren't quite as good as
they make it out to be the people lying
cheating stealing you know killing each
other all those sorts of things back
back then what's fun of this so can't
you will it to be a good original I
can't imagine a circumstance in which
everybody would do that or would there
be some sort of contradiction so that's
one of the things we're going
like the other thing is there might be
cases where you could imagine such a
world but it wouldn't make sense for you
will there be something that sort of
inherently screwed up with not willing
that anymore
so that's the first formulation the
second formulation is saying act in such
a way that you treat Humanity in
yourself and others always as an end
never simply as a means we'll come back
to that so let's let's actually look at
some examples and I think this will help
us make make sense of it Kahn talks
about four kinds of Jews and you got
introduced to the difference between
perfect and imperfect duties with John's
to another remember the difference
between perfect duties are the ones that
you really have to do imperfect duties
if you don't do them you're not actually
like breaking the moral law but it would
be better for than you to do them than
that remember the difference between
those two okay now who do you have
duties to if you had to break it down
two big categories do you have to do
this to yourself yeah everybody else
although other people count doesn't
think you have like duties to animals or
two nature's in general or something
else you might be able to construe you
could maybe work walking with slaughter
but in general things about people so
you have duties to yourself and you have
duties to other people and all of your
duties individual Tuesday you have to
other people they just fit into that big
class you're a sovereign Atwater you
have duties to the parents as such those
are other people you have duties to
other people
other people without yourself so let's
look at some of the examples of the
constrictors it talks about this issue
of suicide can you end your life when
your life starts again you know too bad
when you don't like it no longer living
Conte says that you have a strict duty
to preserve your life and so one of the
things that's very attractive about
counsel is that it's very cut and dry at
least on some things you know John
Stuart Mill might say well you know
really depends on your utilitarian
calculations and you know we're pretty
more themed other people if it's not
going to that I guess it would be okay
let's see suffering from a terminal
illness that's very very painful would
it be okay for you to do physician
assisted suicide and mill would probably
say yes if the pain is really terrible
cop would say no he would say you have a
strict duty to preserve your own life
how does he get there well what's the
max of there it's something along the
lines of whatever my life becomes
unsatisfactory whereas he puts it went
from self love I will shorten my life
when it seems to involve more bad things
that would be imagine can you say that
everybody should should behave that way
God says no why can't you
says that it involves a contradiction
and the contradiction is not in
imagining that kind of world
it's in the act itself because what are
you using forget you know like whether
you use this chemical and that chemical
more broadly what are you actually using
in order to end your life yeah you're
using your own what your own capacity
for choice to end that very that very
life so you're using something to
destroy itself consoles that's a
contradiction so you can't will that to
be a universal law of nature there's
there's something inherently
contradictory about that this is kind of
hard about that first probably are not
used to thinking it's a little bit
easier to see this with the strict
beauty that it talks about with respect
to others what's that well like the
example that he uses you need a loan and
you know that you'll never be able to
repay that loan do you lie to the person
that we're getting the long term because
they're not going to give it to you if
she's telling the truth
do you lie to them and say that you will
be able to repay the loan in order to
get this long God says you can't
universalize that let's say that we
didn't make a little bit far broad you
know I will lie I will lie whatever it
is
for me to live to tell the truth now
imagine a world in which everybody did
that this takes a little bit of you know
thinking of them imagine what that would
be like yeah no politician well a lot of
politicians lie but they don't lie all
the time all right
you know we can think of other classic
but now imagine it's not just F average
all across the board
so it's universal it's not just such
who's lying in Bosnia Texas let me ask
you this this is this will put it in
terms of actually uses if everybody were
to live whatever it's dude stuff we're
gonna break promises or things like that
would the the very distinction between
truth and lies even make sense after a
while we're gonna break down and the
very notion of truth or lying or promise
keeper would cease to make sense
that means the third be a contradiction
because you do know the difference
between telling the truth of the divine
here is there is such a distinction so
you can't actually conceive consistently
a world in which that would be the case
so you can't will that to be the
universal law of nature because it
doesn't even make sense
oh yeah that's talking about what is not
what this is talking about like want to
be people do make exceptions all the
time to this kind of say that they're
behaving in morally there's nothing you
know the in ethics we're never just
basing things on what do people just do
we're saying this is how people actually
fought together so they kind of raised
me at the bar no notice that every time
this is something this is an interesting
point every time that somebody does do
something like that they are making them
soft an exception because that person
who doesn't want other people they are
willing to say everybody shouldn't apply
except for me
in this case because I had some
overriding rule maybe is an example of
this in the other class you know when it
comes to losing your temper you know in
general we see losing your temper is a
bad thing right and we say you shouldn't
lose your temper but it's okay for me in
this case because that person really
hasn't come to them nobody else
understands that that person is such a
complete juror and then if somebody else
tells us cool down or you know don't do
that then we get angry at that as well
and if they get angry at us an attorney
then suddenly it's a universal watch you
shouldn't get angry at me for being
angry we want to make ourselves
exceptions kind of kind of you know very
attuned to the fact that when it comes
to the meritorious or less strict duties
it's a little bit trickier to make sense
out of his
camels he talks about like meritorious
at issue so you should you cultivate
your talents or should you just enjoy
yourself you guys think of experience
that those quite often one requires the
sacrifice and the other in that would
college you know as opposed to the
college experience the way it's
portrayed in movies what is the real
college experience the real college
experience is like a party all the time
yeah it's you know forget the books you
know there's a party every night there's
no there's no consequences to that right
because you get you know think about
like go way way back so you can always
like you know trick the Dean or
something like that get information
that's there what's the reality where
you work almost everyone safe for work
TVs reading you have to force yourself
what do you say I said necessarily gain
pleasure from yeah so let's make it
really struck just studying install
versus enjoying yourself
now why are you doing all that studying
that's to cultivate your your talents
your in something field that you want to
pursue presumably because somebody
really odd recognize you might actually
be good at that and hopefully you picked
something that you actually enjoy doing
alright
usually we do it
and you're getting better and better and
better at right you're not where you
were when you first came to Paris my
hope when it comes to your major
are you hopefully you get that that
degree you're gonna really change the
line so now everybody makes that choice
I'll do that some of your classmates
have dropped out haven't then and
sometimes it could be you know they have
medical problems or you know there's a
problem the family but sometimes they
just want to enjoy themselves
yeah my friend didn't go to college but
he's still using his talents to do what
yeah I'm not saying that cultivating
entails necessarily it's been effective
and I have an uncle a cousin and I was
really proud of my because he hung
drywall since he was 16 I was his only
job he is 53 and he's been about
ironworkers for three years he was a
high school
driver they did really good job hanging
drywall doing things going into the
ironworkers mat changing his career path
at 50 years old
and having to go back to school what I'm
most proud of them for is that he got
straight A's you went back you know they
have to do this
these studies at Community College and
it's not just you know learning how well
although that's pretty important too if
you had to learn something about
metallurgy it's not just pointing at a
flame of things you actually know what
you're doing there's some scientific
processes there he had to take classes
in labor history gotta take that Susan
Wright do all these sorts of things
and he got straight A's because he
invited and he didn't realize that he
had those talents like a talent for
writing which is probably not gonna help
him that launches as America but it's
still part of a mansion the world in
which everybody has their back stone I'm
just going to drive myself I'm not going
to cultivate my talents could that be a
universal law of nature could you have a
universal condition in which everybody I
think you could have management let's
say we do a little bit of science
fiction stuff like we say you know
robots so we can't actually yeah
something like the college experience as
its portrayed in the movies all the time
we just eat drink go to concerts hook up
with people have conversations watch TV
play xbox use drugs sure and play play
games but we don't actually play them
that well you know so you know pickup
games but we don't call too simplistic
Alex couldn't imagine that sort of like
yeah that that could work Khan says that
doesn't actually make sense for you to
will you know why a rational be the kind
of being that you are has
sort of in internal desire to make what
it is flourish to the flower to develop
its potential if you actually have
talents and capabilities and you don't
develop them there's something that's
going to be missing even and all that
enjoyment comments a rational being
cannot will that their faculties not be
developed then you can say well what
about people who are doing I mean
there's there's some people just sit
around and drink beer and eat pizza and
play xbox all right they actually know a
few cameras say you can choose to do
that there is that we do have that
capacity but there's something less than
human about such a life and that you
know that person may at some point come
to realize that and say thank you you
know this is the wrong thing for me to
do I can't live like that
another example of not strict duties to
other people being
was it color benevolent so you know
doing everything that you're supposed to
do and then going a little bit further
that's being done just giving people
what you over that's not yet being
benevolent that's just being just doing
this right
do you also go beyond that help people
even though you don't have to even
though there's no requirement things can
you imagine the world in which none of
us do that in which we all stay Kate so
long as I obey the law and don't violate
anybody else's rights I'm not doing
anything else forget everyone else yeah
you could imagine that could make sense
would you watch a little roll like that
yeah well you always do the example of
the old lady crossing the street yeah
one day we're gonna be old and hopefully
if the car isn't have to run very very
something along those lines somebody
else will help us out that yeah this
kind of goes along the lines in virtue
ethics more than this you're kind of
setting an example
so therefore hoping that everybody else
will follow it so yeah it becomes a
universal law at that point of time when
they see everybody doing this think of
it as an example so much that would fit
in with Virginia that you write how
things have been in terms of just
whether it can be a universal condition
than whether you can can will it
consistently yeah you're right you will
someday be if you live that old man or
that old lady's crossing the street as I
said to the other class just you know
less than 25 years ago you guys were not
in the condition that you are right now
somebody was changing your diapers an
Imagine yeah everybody said ah for
everybody else you know they didn't they
didn't attend to your needs and your
desires somebody was nice to you at some
time right somewhere down the line
otherwise you wouldn't be the
well-adjusted people that you are here
sitting in my classroom today probably
wouldn't be embarrassed so you can't
consistently will this kind of world
even though that kind of world could
exist
you can't consistently is what
confidence let's think about some other
examples these are contexts animals so
now yeah
to do good things to people but you can
consistently know people say that one
more time how can you now it
consistently will people to be
benevolent but you can consistently
little people oh okay because I think I
don't know I I think of the building
rule yeah do what other people want
their do to others if you want to be
done yourself heads a universal rule
then not this too he actually brings it
up that fencer there were a lot of
knocks in there so if I understood
you're saying the two things everything
one is you do have a positive duty to
not live and you also have a meritorious
strict duty to and the question was how
can you up in line he is strictly well
come out the reason why it's the strict
duty you can't will line itself you
don't even have to worry about that the
willing at this point doesn't even make
sense to talk wall everybody follow the
it doesn't even make sense where is a
world in which we don't cultivate our
talents or a world in which we aren't
but not to other people we can imagine
it becomes a question if you were to
switch it talked about tongue the truth
can you say we want to tell the truth
yes
can that be a universal law of nature
yes you can imagine a world which
everybody does television we don't live
right you can't imagine that role can
you consistently will them sure order
the benevolence can you imagine a world
in which everybody is nice and goes
beyond their strict duties to help other
people you can even say that would be a
good thing I can will this sort of as a
matter of fact if you were out there
volunteering and the different Stilicho
district and meritorious duties you have
to do these you have to see the
strangers yeah well that's what it means
to say something secret whether you're
contra Miller if you say your ex tricked
you to do it if you don't do it you're
violating yeah the way I understand it's
like the consequences of everybody
lining is larger than everybody not
being super nice to one another
basically everybody lying all the time
builds the struts and no one's going to
want to
even have anything to do yeah rather
than the van elements aspect yes it
would be nice to have that but it's not
necessarily requiring for society to
operate now that sounds more like John
Stuart Mill right but I'm on this
council trying to get away from
consequences right this is wrong no I
actually this is a criticism
material entirely I myself AM of our
tech buying that I'm not a coach yet I'm
not sure that his arguments really do
hold up I'm nothing with philosopher who
feels that way you're not you're
certainly not the only person who's
who's have these sort of worries about
the one good thing once you figure out
that something is a duty you're done you
have to you know this is required once
you figure out that something is against
morality there are some pleasant cases
let's look at a few other examples
though with trying to use this this
universalization one and then we'll look
at the other
same-same so instead of preserving one's
life let's think about doing anything
whatsoever to make money like
prostituting one so home selling drugs
making porn people you know typically
proud of kept by the way was very it
should what should the maximum it should
be whenever I need money or other
resources I will do anything whatsoever
even if it's degrading to attain them
right can you will this be a universal
law of nature could we imagine a world
in which everybody whatever they needed
money would do any sort of degrading
thing
I think we probably like that could you
build that word would be exist in such a
world I think I would say no this is so
the way this is more like the
cultivating one's talents
what about working on bad dispositions
again
you have to be a strict unity or
anything that would be a meritorious
duty like let's say you brought up pride
let's say you're really really fragile
or you have a really bad temper or what
are some other bad dispositions with
drop let's say you're addicted hey why
don't you wear like a personal duty it
would also be a duty to others but
working on yourself what the answer is
yeah is it a duty to yourself or to
others maybe in some ways it could be
both maybe you should work on your
temperance other people but maybe also
duty to yourself sure if you're addicted
to drugs that would certainly do news to
yourself if your privately probably
actually don't even see the pride as
being a problem well
over the Maxim's it would be something
like when I identify a moral failure or
weakness or bad character to myself I
will do whatever I can to change that
could that be a universal law of nature
could you imagine a everybody myself
included a world in which we don't make
excuses and put it off until next year
or something like that but we actually
do make positive changes in our
personality sure you can consistently
well not compensate well that's what the
world do neither you actually have a
world to yourself
is what we're saying well in the whole
world you don't even think about your
society the whole world of this universe
let's think about some some other
examples here's an issue that comes up
with content he doesn't discuss it this
one it sounds like constants obviously
don't make yourself happy duty duty but
if you have a duty to make yourself
happy
I mean if you're an unhappy person are
you gonna have a much harder time being
the devil into other people ready then
if you're an unhappy person in general
might be a boring sentence to lie cheat
and steal so maybe you actually have a
duty to make yourself do what makes me
happy
the 1960s do it do it feels good man and
all that kind of thing because then
you're doing it Charles Manson
it felt good for get ability to order
the killings I would say something like
when or insofar as it will help me to do
my other duties to other people I will
make myself I will take what I what
steps I need to do to make myself happy
so there's gonna be some internal limits
on that you're not going to pursue
happiness to the detriment of people so
let's say you have take a really
concrete example we have it's gonna be a
lot easier to take care of the older
person if you are relatively happy in
your life but if you're unhappy
there's gonna be a lot of time taking a
lot more temptations to treat them
poorly we often say q15 if you're a
caretaker you should take care of
yourself first and then you can take
care of other people there will be
limits though you can't say well you
know playing xbox 15 hours a day makes
me really happy so in order for me to
take care of my agent at the end the
other three hours I'm going to play xbox
yeah first of the day right that would
interfere with the fulfilling those
those other duties but you could I mean
this would work you could say that the
maximum was something like I will make
myself happy because it can conduces to
my ability to fulfill my duties people
that can be a universal law of nature
you can imagine a world
but has that structure of motivation and
you can will that - I think that makes
sense for all of you to say yeah people
should take care of themselves so they
can take care of others all right does
that makes it does that make sense for
you to Widow I think I think so let's
move now quickly to the another
formulation I think some of these pieces
are to follow the place you know think
about them in terms of this act in such
a way they treat humanity in yourself
and another always as an end never
simply as a means so this means that
everybody is supposed to be treated with
human dignity each one of you has an
inherent worth to you you're not just a
thing there's there's a there's a
fundamental difference between you and
this this has a price it can be
purchased you have work or dignity and
this can never have them doesn't matter
how sophisticated Siri gets actually
have Siri on this one because it's a
Python 3 I'm gonna upgrade eventually
and then I'll have Siri and Siri can
handle a lot of my problems
Siri is not a person you are
even if artificial intelligence advances
very far beyond and we start worrying
about these questions is Syria person
now confident said no it's not you
haven't here work you are able to make
choices you were able to set ends for
yourself and that gives you a value
beyond any other animal any piece of
technology
you can see bro so you should not be
treated solely as a means nor should you
treat other people that way and you know
if you want to think of examples of how
people have treated as means think of
when people married for money but it was
marriages it's this arrangement between
two people that presumably is more than
just a mere financial or sexual
Orangeman it reflects you know certain
ideals that we have otherwise just shack
up right if all you want is the money
and the sax then don't get married
because there's extra stuff that goes
along with it expectations right the
person who's marrying the other person
for money is treating them merely as a
means to getting money what about the
other person they might actually be
treating the other person as a means to
right oftentimes when people are married
for money
aren't they expecting something else in
return for that like you know the other
person either a trophy husband or wife
but they're not often interested in that
person as a person
they don't value it enough yourselves
they're treating there was a meetings
and you can think of all different ways
in which you would treat other people
this means you're lying to people are
you treating them as an N are you
treating them as somebody's shooting
those a means to whatever it is that you
want that's why you're lying to you know
if you're you want people to like you so
you lie to them themselves or things
that you have in common
you're treating one of those it means to
that feeling of being left what about
what about killing yourself to take the
suicide you're treating yourself again
as a means for treating Humanity in
yourself or if you choose not to develop
your talents just enjoy yourself you're
using your human potential as just a
mere means to enjoying yourself and
you're not treating yourself it's a
fully human as a result
don't be a case where you have dignity
but you're acting in an undignified way
sort of lower I think you would see the
same thing about doing just about
anything for money you know say selling
drugs engaging in prostitution
type or what other where are the things
people consider keep reading we said
this is an honest work taking bribes
that's a good example
what intercepts tripperz tripperz yeah I
guess that would be sort of the same
sort of range the prostitution court
stripping of the along say taking bribe
to be really interesting because you
would not only be treating yourself is
amazed you would also be treating the
people that you take bribes from
and the people who are going to and
suffering because of the bribes that you
take as means to your you know financial
we could probably think of things like
that
there's stripper who cheats their
clients doesn't that take choice out of
the picture are you no longer making
choices individual individuals we assume
that all would be universal in nature or
anybody else the same yeah that's a good
question how does that make it you're
only doing this was sort of a
hypothetical exercise so you are
actually still choosing you're choosing
to act in such a way that you think
everyone that else a lot to be doing
even recognize me in this world
that you're choosing to resist the
temptation to make exceptions for
yourself as well that isn't that is
still involving choice now there is
another point of this though you're
right to point out that if that were in
fact the case let's assume that we were
all like super well-adjusted
yeah like concepts we have no
inclinations that would be contrary do
so we always wanted no duty to follow
Duty is a choice and to follow duty for
the sake of Duty it is also a choice
because you can choose to follow it just
to practice under table but let's let's
think about this for a second this is a
good good question what have we all were
angels what if we all had perfect
structures of motivation and we've
always wanted to do the right thing the
thing that could be universalized
and you know there really wasn't any
choice involved count would say well
that point it wouldn't be the problem we
wouldn't talk about duty we wouldn't
talk about morality
we'd all like be in heaven so there is a
live question with those beings imagine
the beings of heaven I can't choose to
do the wrong things are we in some way
better than them when we choose to do
the right thing even though we're
tempted longer because I can't choose
that's a good question to think about do
we have a greater dignity in choosing
the right and we're tempted you
sacrifice some being
yeah yeah I mean I think the key thing
in regards to choice I mean he says it
right there it's three to three years
well yeah like what would you will you
could choose to will it or not that
that's the whole thing yeah I believe it
like even ages like if we take it like
in that category you have then develop
who became that you know they still have
a choice
there's no there is there is never
necessary like a perfect society even
people who are good they're good because
they choose to be good
yeah well this this is an interesting
theological I'm gonna come back to some
some other people that I work on you
talk about I wanted you know one other
example to help you think about this
issue
think about the duties there that are
involved with character okay you're
supposed to do a parent we're supposed
to do about provide a lot of different
things to your kids including shelter
safety yeah love could you be a parent
without being loving towards their kids
you could would you be treating them as
an end in themselves if you weren't
loving towards their kids or will you be
treating them as as a mirror means and
remember kids are you know and you've
all been kids and your mom okay
kids are not lovable objects all the
time and they're they're cute it's easy
to love them but that they start
misbehaving and you know that's pretty
early on
true they start contradicting you and
then they start fighting more and more
ways to get themselves in trouble and
screw things up and you know make make
your life revolve around them well this
would be humanity isn't them do you
treat them as an end or just as there's
a lot of ways to treat your kids just as
means aren't there we've all known the
character that makes the kid an
extension of themselves and they sort of
live out their dreams through making the
kid do the things that they wanted to do
in school that they never got to do that
would be treating the kid is just a
means limit not a lot of the child to
develop and explore their own
individuality and their own desires and
make some choices if you tell your kid
you're going to be on the chess team or
drama or you're gonna play this
instrument but you're gonna play this
sport or something like that where
you're going to get good grades because
I got good grades and you don't leave it
up to the the kid to find these things
attractive I think you can say that that
person who's treating the
means compensates oh that's an
interesting question
creating them for the way tailoring the
the child genetic profiles what they'll
have certain I think their son yeah I
agree that cop would say the dance sort
of genetic manipulation or let's say you
know that the practice reading female
Lynch at that would be treating that
child as a means to the ends of your
design not treating that child is having
an engineer
we're in a dignity individuality of
itself
yeah that's a good question I need to
think more about that to get what you
want to that child which society what
you think society should be rather than
ends to the end of it
yeah and some that you're reducing the
individual to just like nog at the
machine something that's a value to
society and not value in and of itself
so that's cool